en quelques minutes dimanche ou de
plongeon extrême donc c'est parti
[Musique]
et ça c'est mon top depuis je le fais
quatre heures par jour
[Musique]
j'ai vu une annonce sur facebook il
disait qu'il recherchait des plongeurs
pour les pays bas et j'ai candidaté du
coup je suis ici non maintenant voilà
pour la saison estivale donc là j'arrive
au boulot et on est aux pays-bas du coup
c'est en vélo forcément car c'est ça des
moyens de transport le plus utilisé
on arrive à 8h30 on s'entraîne jusqu'à
l'ouverture du parc qui à 10 heures
alors je me suis retrouvé avec de quoi
faire du plongeant parce que j'ai
commencé par la gymnastique et le
trampoline plus petit et j'ai vraiment
toujours adoré l'acrobatie et donc plus
tard quand j'étais sûr en vacances sur
les pompes fois j'ai commencé à faire
des acrobaties et avec les réseaux
sociaux j'ai vu qu'ils avaient des gens
qui sont des trucs de ouf je me suis dit
que c'était de le truc il fallait que je
sais c'est ça reste hyper dangereux mais
j'ai toujours eu le goût pour
l'adrénaline
les frissons et j'adore toujours
repousser mes limites morales ont
[Musique]
fait quatre spectacles par jour qui
durera environ 25 minutes chaque
spectacle commence le premier show à
12h30 et le dernier show est à 18h30
[Musique]
il ya tout un travail de musculation et
de préparation physique qui est vraiment
important et n'a pas négligé et ensuite
pendant les shows donc juste avant il
faut aussi se préparer mentalement donc
prendre son temps bien respirer à
montceau puisqu'on on met autour de
notre vie en jeu donc il faut il faut
rester conscient et toujours être
vigilant 100% tous les jours
bien sûr j'ai peur à mon chaque saut et
si je n'ai pas peur mais c'est dangereux
parce que c'est là où je commencerai à
peut-être être moins concentrée et a
raté un saut et ce qui peut être fatale
[Musique]
à
moi je suis du sud de la france mais je
loge ici pour toute la saison donc c'est
une maison toute l'équipe est habité
ensemble du coup on est cet avis dans la
maison et c'est toute l'équipe je suis
l'un des plus jeunes car j'ai tout juste
18 ans j'ai passé mon bac juste avant de
devenir mes parents moi comme comme j'ai
toujours été un casse cou depuis tout
petit ils sont ils sont préparés
habitués même si ça alors fait toujours
peur qu'on voit les vidéos quand ils
voient cendres et que j'ai toujours rêvé
de travailler dans le monde du spectacle
devait être artiste c'est une job dating
très particulier puisque c'est dangereux
donc donc il faut être bien préparé et
bien savoir ce qu'on fait est toujours
toujours être concentré à 100% et donc
c'est de nous faire une bonne
préparation mais après c'était plus
qu'un choc j'étais puisque c'est
vraiment ma passion et j'aimerais
continuer à faire ça et croissance un
job d'été mais j'aimerais arrive à faire
ça tout le long de l'année